à des autres grands problèmes monsieur
le Président actuellement pour
l'ensemble des Français les sondages le
prouvent à l'heure actuelle c'est le
pétrole et dans ce domaine peut-être à
cause de quelques déclarations de
membres du gouvernement pas très bien
ajusté certains se demandent si on dit
la vérité aux Français en matière de la
politique du pétrole alors quelle est
cette vérité en d'autres termes va-t-on
manquer de pétrole ou bien non Macron
pas dans les six mois
je ne sais pas ce que vous appelez
l'ajustement des déclarations n'est-ce
pas mais ce que je sais c'est que le
problème du pétrole est à l'heure
actuelle en effet un problème très
actuel très
sérieux et que la vérité est bien elle
est très simple et je suis prêt à ce qui
me concerne à la dire cette vérité la
voici
tout d'abord
notre politique
l'état de nosto le rythme actuel de nos
importations
font que nous sommes à l'abri d'une
crise grave dans les prochains mois
c'est un premier point et qui a je crois
de l'importance
en second lieu
il faut reconnaître que la hausse des
prix du pétrole
aura une incidence sérieuse sur nos
prises intérieures il faut le savoir et
il faut s'y préparer
en troisième lieu
il est exact
que dans une économie qui était basée
sur l'échange et sur la liberté du
commerce
les raffineries françaises ne
produisaient pas toujours tous les
produits pétroliers
nécessaires à notre consommation je
prendrai un exemple le Balzen est bien
nous importons nous importions une bonne
part du bal zen de l'étranger en
particulier des États-Unis
et naturellement la situation actuelle
où chacun tente à garder ce qu'il a fait
que cela crée des problèmes et des
difficultés dans quelques industries
comme par exemple les plastiques c'est
vrai nous nous préparons à trouver des
solutions et des contre-mesures mais
cela reste en tout cas localise
en quatrième lieu
il est certes
que si la pénurie de pétrole devait se
prolonger pendant des mois et des années
et bien tous les pays finiraient par en
subir les conséquences directes ou
indirectes
et que par conséquent le devoir du
gouvernement et de se préparer à prendre
le cas échéant des mesures
sérieuses des mesures graves il s'y
préparent il n'est pas dit qu'il les
prendra forcément et à l'heure actuelle
il n'a pas à prendre et il a besoin en
tout cas de personnes pour l'inciter à
les prendre néanmoins nous avons nommé
un délégué général à l'énergie nous
avons pris un certain nombre de textes
qui nous donne les moyens d'intervenir
à ce type de mesure je fais appel et
nous faisons appel avant tout à cette
vertu traditionnelle paraît-il du peuple
français qui est l'esprit d'économie
économisons l'essence
économisons l'électricité
économisant le chauffage et cela seul
suffira à diminuer notre consommation et
par la même
à
paré à quelques difficultés
d'importation
et aussi à atténuer les effets sur la
hausse des prix et sur notre commerce
extérieur que tous les Français veulent
bien veuillent bien en pareil matière et
dès l'action gouvernementale et mon Dieu
nous arriverons bien je l'espère à
surmonter les difficultés autrement dit
monsieur le Président on a l'impression
à vous entendant que nous sommes tout de
même dans une certaine situation
privilégiée
privilégiez c'est beaucoup dire c'est
peut-être trop dit
mais enfin il est peut-être pas besoin
de grands efforts pour trouver d'autres
pays qui dans pas mal de domaines ont à
l'heure actuelle plus de difficultés que
la France
il n'allait pas moins vrai que nous nous
trouvons
à l'aube d'une année difficile nous
sommes en fin d'année c'est pas l'aube
enfin la nouvelle année va commencer
bientôt et je le dirai aux Français le
31 décembre nous sommes au bord d'une
année difficile sans aucun
et c'est pourquoi
ce qu'il faut
ce n'est pas la grogne
c'est l'effort
ce n'est pas le laisser aller c'est
l'action ce n'est pas les divisions
c'est l'union
si les Français veulent bien le
comprendre
et
se serrer les coudes et aider l'action
gouvernementale et bien comme je le
disais tout à l'heure l'année 1974 sera
certainement pas une année de facilité
mais elle ne sera pas non plus une année
catastrophique comme un certain nombre
de gens le prédisent ou se plaisent à le
prédire monsieur le Président une
photographie de l'opinion ce matin même
et vous devez avoir ce sondage sur votre
bureau dit que trois Français sur 4,75%
des Français en gros sont non pas me
roses mais plutôt inquiet j'imagine que
parmi ces motifs d'inquiétude il y a les
prix alors que faire pour les prix les
Français sont inquiets parce que il se
réveille d'un trop beau rêve
même en tenant compte mais malheureux
des pauvres des vieillards et des
déshérités en gros la vie française
était une vie de facilité et de bonheur
même si les Français ne se rendaient pas
toujours cons et d'ailleurs d'autres
sondages ont montré qu'il s'en rendait
compte et peut-être après tout l'action
du gouvernement n'était-elle pas
complètement étrange
la hausse des prix c'est en effet
un problème préoccupant
parmi
les causes de cette hausse des prix il y
en a quelques-unes dont nous ne sommes
pas les seuls maîtres par exemple le
prix de l'énergie le prix des matières
premières
mais il y en a d'autres qui dépendent de
nous sur le plan intérieur
et elle ne dépendent pas simplement de
l'action du gouvernement des mesures
qu'ils pourraient prendre elles
dépendent de chaque Français et de son
attitude en tant que consommateur et que
producteur en tant que travailleur et en
tant de patron en tant que commerçant si
chacun veut bien à sa place non pas
chercher à se débrouiller mais chercher
au contraire à s'unir pour un effort
commun alors nous avons
une meilleure chance de limiter la
hausse des prix dans une dans des
proportions raisonnables et d’éviter par
la même des mesures brutales des mesures
brutales que le peuple français n'aime
pas
on l'a bien vu en diverses occasions et
qui d'ailleurs ne sont pas pleinement
efficaces là encore je fais appel à tous
en prévenant chaque catégorie sociale
qu'elle souffrira d'autant plus de ces
mesures qu'elle aura moins bien compris
l'importance de son rôle que tout le
monde comprenne dans chaque catégorie
dans chaque profession l'importance de
son rôle et alors et bien alors là
encore le pire sera évité
[Musique]